>>> TOP ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
SAYS GEORGIA IS FINISHED TO IRE
JBIDEN'S VICTORY
IN THE STATE.
A GROWING NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
ARE BLASTING LINDSEY GRAHAM
AFTER STUNNING CLAIMS FROM
GEORGIA SECRETARY OF STATE THAT
GRAHAM HINTED HE THOUGHT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE SHOULD FD A
WAY TO DISREGARD LEGALLY CAST
ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
>> I ASKED THAT THE BALLOTS
COULD BE MATCHED BACKO
VOTERS AND THEN I GOT THE SENSE
IT IMPLIED THAT THEN YOU COULD
THROW THOSE OUT AND LOOK AT THE
COUNTIESIT HIGHEST
FREQUENT ERROR OF SIGNATURES.
IT WAS JUST AN IMPLICATION THAT
LOOK HARD AND SEE HOW MANY
BALLOTS YOU COULD THROW OUT. SE
CLAIM CALLING IT RIDICULOUS.
CNN MANU WAS LIVE ON CAPITOL
HILL.
YOU SPOKE WITH SENATOR GRAHAM
TODAY.
A STUNNING CHARGE OF REA
SHADINESS.
WHAT ELSE IS GRAHAM SAYING?
>> CHARGE FROM A FELLOW
REPUBLICAN OFFICIAL.
GRAHAM IS DEFENDING HIS EFFORTS.
HE SAID THAT HE SIMPLY HAD
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WAY MAIL-I
VOTING IS OCCURRING IN KEY
STATES AND RAISING CONCERNS
ABOUT THE MAIL-IN VOTING PROCESS
TO ENSURE THAT SIGNATURES ARE
VERIFIED TO DO JUST THAT.
HE REVEALED TODAY HE DIDN'T CALL
JUST GEORGIA OFFICIALS BUT TWO
OTHER STATES WHERE JOE BIDEN IS
PROJECTED TO WIN IN ARIZONA AND
NEVADA.
IN MY CONVEATITH HIM
TODAY HE ALSO CONTENDED HE WA T
COULD MAKE STRICTER THOSE VOTER
VERIFICATION RULES IN GEORGIA
AHEAD OF THE SENATE RUNOFFS THAT
WILL DETERMINE THE NEXT
MAJORITY.
>> WHAT I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
IS IF YOU CONTINUE TO VOTE BY
MAIL THAT WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT
SYSTEMS WORK AND WHAT DON'T.
IT'S UP TO THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA.
I THINK EVERY RIGHT IN THE WORLD
TO REACH OUT AND SAY HOW DOES IT
WORK?
WHAT I DID.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A PRETTY GOOD
CONVERSATION.
>> Reporter:
[ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ]
>> I REJECT THAT.
THAT WASN'T MY INTENT TO THROW .
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AN ELECTION
WE HAVEN'T HAD YET WHICH IS THE
SENATE RACES.
THAT WAS MY FOCUS.
>> Reporter: PART OF THE REASON
LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS GOTTEN SO
MUCH CK HE IS A CLOSE
TRUMP ALLY AND CHAIRMAN OF A
COE.
AND MITCHELL McCONNELL I ASKED
HIM IF HE IS OKAY WHAT LINDSEY
GRAHAM IS DOING AND HE SAID ASK
LINDSEY GRAHAM ABOUT THAT AND
CHUCK SCHUMER CALLED IT
RECKLESS.
>> HE CALLED THREE STATES THAT
JOE BIDEN WON.
HE DIDN'T CALL THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS NORTH OF SOUTH
CAROLINA IN NORTH CAROLINA WHERE
TRUMP ONE.
THAT DIDN'T OCCUR HIM?
JUST THE ONES THAT BIDEN WON.
INTERESTING.
LET'S DISCUSS.
MANU, THANKS SO MUCH.
ABBY, PRESIDENT AND MANY
REPUBLANREFUSING TO PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT PRESIDENT-ELECT
BIDEN IS PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN.
A FIST PUMP HERE HERE AND TIM
SCOTT AND OTHERS APPEARING TO
CONGRATULATE INCOMING VICE
PRESIDENT-ELECT KAMALA HARRIS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
SEE THAT?
>> IT'S SO INTERESTING, JAKE,
THESE REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS WOULD
BE WILLING TO CONGRATULATE
SENATOR HARRIS AND I THINK IN
ONE CASE DISCUSS WITH HER WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO HER SENATE SEAT
BACK IN CALIFORNIA BUT NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS ELECTION IS
OVER AND THAT JOE BIDEN IS THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
IT REALLY HIGHLIGHTS THAT ALL OF
THIS IS -- PERHAPS THEY VIEW IT
AS POLITICAL THEATER BUT I THINK
WE KNOW THERE IS WHETHER THERE
IS A REAL CHANCEHEEX
RESULTS CAN BE OVERTURNED.
>> NOT TO MENTION NOT ALLOWING
THE TRANSITION WHEN IT HAS TO DO
OR THE TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
JACKIE, LINDSEY GRAHAM IS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE RESPONSE
WOULD BE IF THE DEMOCRATIC
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STARTED CALLING
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL I STATES
THAT TRUMP ONE NARROWLY LIKE
NORTH CAROLINA AND ASKED ABOUT
ABSENTEE BALLOTS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE RESPONSE
WOULD BE FROM THE MAGA MEDIA?
>> I THINK FOX NEWS WOULD BE
ABLAZED AND YOU COULD SEE IT
FROM SPACE.
THAT IS NOT HAPPENING HERE.
SECRETARY OF STATE GEORGIA ONE
OF HIS TOP AIDES WAS AT THE CALL
AND BACK HIM UP THAT LINDSEY
GRAHAM'S IMPRESSION OF THE CALL
IS INCORRECT CORRECT AND THE
GEORGIA SECRETARY OF STATE IS
TELLING T TRUTH.
FRANKLY, I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS THAT WOULD
APPRECIATE ANYONE GETTING
INVOLVED IN THE FEDERAL LEVEL
INTO THEIR STATE.
STATES AREEL AT THE, YOU
KNOW, STATES IS KIND OF A
REPUBLICAN THG.
THE FACT THAT LINDSEY GRAHAM
KIND OF WANTED TO SEE HOW THINGS
WORKED IN GEORGIA IS NONE OF
BUSINESS.
AN YOU CAN ONLY EXTRAPOLATE WHY
HE WAS DOING THAT.
>> HE TOLD MANU HE HAD
INTERESTING QUESTIONS ABOUT
SIGNATURES ON BALLOTS AND WHAT
IS GOING TO WORK.
CNN HAS LEARNED THAT CNN PLANS
TO CONFIRM THE HAND COUNT
TOMORROW.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS ALLIES ARE SEARCHING FOR
ANY EVIDENCE THAT THEY CAN FIND
OF FRAUD.
THEY HAVE FOUND NONE SO FAR.
THEY ARE SEARCHING DESPERATELY
FOR IT.
ONE OF THE MAIN AVENUES IS
LOOKING AT THE SIGNATURE
VERIFICATIONS, SPECIFICALLY THE
WAY YOU SIGN YOUR BALLOT AND
ATCHED UP AGAINST ANOTHER
SIGNATURE THAT IS ON RECORD.
OUNDS LIKE WHAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE RAFFENSPERGER
WAS SAYING HE WAS INQUIRING
ABOUT THE RATE AT WHICH THOSE
ARE THROWN OUT AND WHETHER THAT
COULD BE AN INDICATION THAT THEY
COULD IMPLY THERE WAS WIDESPREAD
FRAUD.
THIS IS A FOOL'S ERRANT, I
THINK, LARGELY.
BECAE  HAVE VERIFICATION
ARE THE STRINGENT FOR MAIL-IN
VOTING.
IT'S EVIDENCE THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING WHERE THERE IS
REALLY NOTHING.THINK THIS IDEA D
THROW OUT VOTES IN BULK IS SO
FRANKLY ANTI-DIAGRAMMATIC IN
NA --
ANTI-DEMOCRATIC IN NATURE.
IF YOU THROW THEM OUT IT'S ON
INDIVIDUAL MERS NOTE ON A
WHOLE.
I THINK THIS WHOLE IDEA IS ONE
THAT IS PRETTY DISTURBING WHEN
YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPLICATION IS OF ALL OF THIS.
>> IN FACT, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE OF GEORGIA , JACKIE,
THAT THERE ARE 24,000 MORE
REPUBLICANS THAT VOTED IN THE
PRIMARY THAN VOTED IN THE
GENERAL AFTER TRUMP BEGAN HIS
CRUSADE SLAMMING VOTE BY MAIL.
THERE IS YOUR MARGIN OF VICTORY
RIGHT THERE FOR JOE BIDEN.
24,000 REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED IN
THE PRIMARY BUT NOT THE GENERAL
ELECTION WHEN JOE BIDEN WON BY
ALMOST 14,000 VOTES?
THAT IS IT.
IF TRUMP IS LOOKING FOR A REASO
HE DON VOTE-BY-MAIL.
>> RIGHT.
WHICH IS WHY YOU HAD OTHER
STATES LIKE NORTH CAROLINA, I'M
NOT SURE THE GEORGIA GOP DID
THIS.
THEY WERE TRYING TO UNRING THAT
BELL.
GE THAT ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE RUNOFFS THAT
ARE COMING UP IN JANUARY THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES
CONTINUING TO SLAIA AND
CONTINUING TO SLAM HOW GEORGIA
IS DOING THIS RECOUNT IS GOING
TO DIMINISH THE TRUST IN THE
GEORGIA ELECTION EVEN GOING
FORWARD.
PERHAPSDSEY GRAHAM SHOULD
LOOK AT THAT AS HE TOLD MANU HE
IS LOOKING TOWARD THE NEXT
ELECTION BECAUSE THAT IS
SOMETHING WE ARE HEARING FROM
OUR SOURCES THAT GEORGIA
REPUBLICANS ARE ACTUALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> ABBY, DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
JEFFRIES IS CALLING FOR A
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION
INTO LINDSEY GRAHAM.
DO YOU THINK IT MIGHT GO THAT
FAR?
>> PROBABLY NOT IN THE NEXT 60
DAYS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S AN OPEN QUESTION AFTER THAT
IF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD
BE ENGAGED IN ANY KIND OF
INVESTIGATIONS LIKE THAT IN A
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE IF
THE REPORTING IS CORRECT, BIDEN
IS TRYING TO TAMP DOWN ON SOME
OF THIS TALK.
I THINK THIS IS ONE OF T
THINGS YOU MIGHT WANT TO LET GO
AND ALSO NOT CLEAR HOW EXPLICIT
WHAT LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID WAS.
CLEARLY THE IMPLICATION WAS
THERE.
RAFFENSPERGER WHO IS A
REPUBLICAN TOOK IT ONE WAY BUT
GRAHAM IS REALLY PLAYING I THINK
A DANGEROUS GAME HERE.
IF HE IS COMPLYING TO ELECTION
OFFICIALS THEY OUGHT TO DO
SOMETHING THEY THINK IS
UNETHICAL OR POTENTIALLY
ILLEGAL, IT'S JUST NOT A GAME
YOU WANT TO PLAY IF YOU'RE A
SITTING UNITED STATES SENATOR.
>> THE SECRETARY OF STATE OF
GEORGIA SAI